In this video I will explain to you everything
we know about rocks, why he might still be
alive as well as a crazy theory by the
best Japanese one piece YouTuber Yuderon
on what really happened at God Valley at the end.
As you've probably figured out by now, I'm a
gigantuous fan of all the legendary characters
in One Piece, we know close to nothing
about. Dragon, Shanks, Imu and recently
Oda has added to this list by introducing us to
the most dangerous pirate crew of the century,
Rocks, and their captain, Rocks D. Xebec, a man so
dangerous the government erased all memory of him.
I remember I was so shocked when I read
that chapter, that I spilled my coffee on
my master thesis. But now I'm a YouTuber,
so I guess it all worked out in the end.
What makes Rocks so incredibly fascinating
to me is that we know for a fact that he
was close to being the most powerful person in
the story. they gyus I mentioned earlier, Imu,
Shanks and Dragon COULD be very powerful,
but they also have a lot of political power that
makes them important. Rocks on the other hand,
had 3 of the 5 yonko we have met so far under him
and is a role model for a 4th. It took both Roger
and Garp, the pirate king and the hero of the
marines teaming up in order to take him down.
If you want me to be excited about your
character, you know what you have to do?
That. Just exactly that.
Hi, my name is Manu, I always thought Geology
was kinda boring, but look, here I am,
excited to talk about Rocks. Huh. Who knew.
So, what do we actually know about this man. Rocks
recruited his powerful and violet crew...violent,
not violet, although... anyways he
recruted them on the island beehive,
that is now Blackbeard's center of operation.
We know that he wanted to rule the world,
and that he was defeated during the
mysterious God Valley incident 40 years ago,
after which the government attempted to
erase him and the island from history.
Now the problem I have with this, is that
we get this information from Sengoku, who
is not as bad as Akainu, but I still think might
just be a teeny tiny bit biast in this regard.
I mean, All pirates are evil in the eyes of
the government, especially the ones who are
a threat to them, something I discussed in my
video on bounties. So while Sengoku probably
tells at least SOME of the truth here,
some of it is probably a big pile of poop.
To me, Garp is usually the best
marine source for information.
Just like Luffy he doesn't lie, but just
shares confidential information left and right.
However Garp hates talking about the
incident. One of the reasons might very
well be that he worked together with a pirate,
but then again it's only one of the reasons.
Garp clearly didn't like what happened
on that island with the celestial
dragons. He is a man that obviously
believes in the good of the marines,
but despises the Nobels, even though he
saved them on that day together with Roger.
And by the way, It's also interesting
that Roger decided to seek Laugh Tale
right after this incident happened.
Hell, I would bet my grandma that
something happened on god valley
that would have been devastating for the
world government, had it come to light.
Something I will discuss in
the Yuderon theory at the e-
Hello? Oh Hallo. It's my mom. Hm? Ach
quatsch das mit Oma war doch nur Spa-. -
ja - ja. Tut mir leid. Ja das war respektlos
von mir. okay. Richt ich aus. - my mom says
hi and sorry for my bad manners. Sorry grandma.
Point is, for all we know, Rocks might well
have been a morally way more complicated
and grey characetr than we think. He
could well have had a noble ideal to
free the world or expose the government,
which would explain why the likes of Big
mom or Whitebeard were part of his crew, who
also believe in a better world for everyone.
Maybe Rocks actually had a good dream, but
tried to reach it through the wrong means.
It's also quite possible, that rocks
knew quite a lot about the true history
since Sengoku mentions this. []
Just like Rayleigh tells Luffy that they
might come to a different conclusion than
they did when reaching Laugh Tale, maybe Rocks
also came to a different conclusion himself.
One thing I want to talk about,
is Beehive Island. Which is a pretty
cute name for what it actually is.
This island, that was Rocks' home base is also
known as the pirate island. And funnily enough,
during the davie back fight arc, Robin explains
that the game originated on that same island.
Now I have to admit that the Davie
Back fight on long ring long island
is the only part of the entire one piece saga that
I find intolerable to watch. Foxy is annoying,
the entire thing is just weird and it's
just too god damn long. No pun intended.
That being said, even though Foxy's games
are terrible, we know that this event is a
quite legitimate thing in the pirate world.
People do take this pretty seriously. And
can you imagine someone like Doflamingo or
Kaido playing Donut race? This is a game that
allows pirates to take crew members
from the opponent and shame them.
I would bet...I'm sure that usually the davie
back fight is a much more dark and serious event.
And the fact that it originated on Beehive
island might tell us that Rocks was only able
to forge a crew of such monsters by playing
this game. Whether that is true or not,
I really hope we get to see some
serious payoff for this arc in
some way or form in the future,
because otherwise, ...why?
Before we get to Yuderon and his
theory, I have one more that I found
really interesting to think about. What
if the entire story about God valley was
false and Rocks actually won that day. He
then crowned himself king of the world,
which would of course have meant the end for
Rocks as a crew. He then erased all evidence
of that place and the events there, including
himself, calling himself Imu from then on out.
That would explain why Roger fought for the
Nobles and why Garp doesn't like talking about it.
Now, do I really believe in this theory?
Not really, I still prefer the one from this video
here. But it's an intriguing thought nonetheless.
By the way, should Rocks actually still be
alive, I have seen some people who say that
he resembles Blackbeard. Or Dragon. But
the first person I thought of when I saw
his silhouette first, was this dude here. Not
very likely, but he looks the most like it.
Okay, time for Yuderon's theory on the god
valley incident. And a quick challenge for you:
Subscribe if you're brave enough.
And of course this wouldn't be a Yuderon theory
without a good ol' wordplay. It's only one this
time though. I promise. And it's more of an
observation than part of the theory. The wordplay
for the legendary chapter 957 where rocks and the
god valley incident are revealed is kyuugouchi,
which in Japanese means rallying place.
This fits, because of the marines gathering,
Beehive, where Rocks gathered his
crew, but especially god valley,
where all of the yonko before blackbeard, Roger,
the marines and the world nobles came together.
Okay I lied there are two wordplays.
The second one is Rocks' name itself. Rokusu. 694.
Chapter 694 is titled 'the most dangerous man',
the cover page features Caribou *caughs*,
and is the climate of the Punk Hazard arc,
that ends with the appearance of
Doflamingo, a former celestial dragon.
Now as you know from my pst videos with Yuderon,
Oda likes to write his story according to the
principle two sides of the same coin, as in:
many of the stories elements have a counterpart
that is similar, but a bit different. If you
want to know more about this, I strongly
suggest you check out those videos after.
Now Punk Hazard seems to be the mirroring
part to god valley, which would mean that
the title also refers to Rocks D. Xebec. So how
are these two islands similar. Well first of all,
in both cases we have 2 Ds joining hands. Luffy
and Law vs. Roger and Garp. Luffy and Law save
the Dragon Momonosuke and the other slave kids,
while Roger and Garp save the celestial dragons
and their slaves. Both islands, god valley
and punk hazard have been turned into secret
islands by the government. However, since
punk hazard still exists, so might God valley.
Now of course the most interesting part about
punk hazard, except the major battle between
aokiji and akainu there, was caesar's secret
lab in which he was producing the chemical for
the fake devil fruits. So if we mirror this,
instead of fake devil fruits we have the real
fruits of the gods. God valley. And this
of course reminds us immediately of the
forbidden fruit in the garden eden. The
Taboo. The taboo that Rocks knew about.
In Japanese god valley is actually called
'goddo baree' and bare I Japanese means to be
exposed. So the island where the secret of
the gods was exposed? And drakes father,
who found the OP OP no mi is called barerusu
in Japanese. Goddo baree and barerusu.
Could the op op no mi be the fruit that
was artificially created on god valley to
give the celestial dragons their immortality? We
already talked about why they could be immortal.
The fruit that Doflamingo, the man with the giant
complex because he was pushed out of heaven,
wanted to have no matter what? To have the
immortality surgery performed on him as well.
Could the clestial dragons have used this island
to force slaves to perform that surgery on them?
And rocks was trying to get his hands on
the fruits? Or did he try something else?
But maybe chapter 694 tells us even more.
What if the celestial dragons that
were defended by garp and Roger
were actually the donquixote family? That
later then decided to leave Marijoe and became
'good'? The only other example of
'good' tenryuubito is none other
than Donquixote Mjosguard, who got saved
by the gold fish mermaid Queen Otohime.
They were saved and got their humanity back one by
gold Roger and the other by the gold fish Otohime.
So it might well be, that
God valley had that name,
because it was the place where gods were made.
If you haven't seen the other
two theories I made with Yuderon,
you have just have to check
them out right on my face.